Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Before we start, it is important to emphasize
that this paper is not using neural networks.
Not so long ago, in 2015, the news took the
world by storm: researchers were able to create
a novel neural network-based technique for
artistic style transfer, which had quickly
become a small subfield of its own within
machine learning.
The problem definition was the following:
we provide an input image and a source photograph,
and the goal is to extract the artistic style
of this photo and apply it to our image.
The results were absolutely stunning, but
at the same time, it was difficult to control
the outcome.
Later, this technique was generalized for
higher resolution images, and instead of waiting
for hours, it now works in almost real time
and is used in several commercial products.
Wow, it is rare to see a new piece of technology
introduced to the markets so quickly!
Really cool!
However, this piece of work showcases a handcrafted
algorithm that only works on a specialized
case of inputs, text-based effects, but in
this domain, it smokes the competition.
And here, the style transfer happens not with
any kind of neural network or other popular
learning algorithm, but in terms of statistics.
In this formulation, we know about the source
text as well, and because of that we know
exactly the kind of effects that are applied
to it.
Kind of like a before and after image for
some beauty product, if you will.
This opens up the possibility of analyzing
its statistical properties and applying a
similar effect to practically any kind of
text input.
The term statistically means that we are not
interested in one isolated case, but we describe
general rules, namely, in what distance from
the text, what is likely to happen to it.
The resulting technique is remarkably robust
and works on a variety of input output pairs,
and is head and shoulders beyond the competition,
including the state of the art neural network-based
techniques.
That is indeed quite remarkable.
I expect graphic designers to be all over
this technique in the very near future.
This is an excellent, really well-written
paper and the evaluation is also of high quality.
If you wish to see how one can do this kind
of magic by hand without resorting to neural
networks, don't miss out on this one and make
sure to have a look!
There is also a possibility of having a small
degree of artistic control over the outputs,
and who knows, some variant of this could
open up the possibility of a fully animated
style transfer from one image.
Wow!
And before we go, we'd like to send a huge
shoutout to our Fellow Scholars who contributed
translations of our episodes for a variety
of languages.
Please note that the names of the contributors
are always available in the video description.
It is really great to see how the series is
becoming more and more available for people
around the globe.
If you wish to contribute, click on the cogwheel
icon in the lower right and the substitles/cc
text.
Thank you so much!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!